Look
[Music]
with your newscast today, Tuesday
, January 12, one of the most
influential people in the history of Nevada
has passed away. We are talking about the
billionaire and owner of the casinos, come,
Jon, and by the way, the precious empire from
Las Vegas to China.  his wife Miriam
the semi las vegas sands confirmed his
death but they are 87 years old he was the
richest man in nevada an icon in
the gaming industry and the governor if
you are light he developed a new
vaccine plan against copper 19 instead  of the
model with different levels
there will now be vaccine lanes
essential workers will be in the
first lane the other will be for the
general population if you work with
the public you will receive priority over
those who work from home
people over the age of 70
will also receive priority adults without health
problems  health between the ages of
16 and 64 will have to wait
longer
station is hardly preparing for the
season of ca  lor and its pools the
company is looking for bartenders and
lifeguards among others the
hiring event will be people during the
next week if you are interested you must
apply online in advance
for more information visit our
page and usher dotcom
now we pass with your weather forecast
is expected  a day with sun and clouds
the temperatures will be 58
degrees and get ready because
70 degrees are approaching starting Thursday until
the weekend have a good day I
am salt and jaramillo and this was illustrated
in Spanish
[Music]